What's included in the four minutes or so
of new footage added to Spider-Man: Far from
Home?
Join us as we break down what's new for the
re-release, why it might have been excluded
from the original cut of the film, and whether
you ought to make another trip to the theater
for it.
As Peter and Ned are leaving school after
finishing up their classes for the year, Peter
rattles off a list of things he has to get
done before the students leave on their European
trip.
First on his list: pick up his passport from
the post office.
When Peter gets there, he finds himself at
the end of a ridiculously long line, which
isn't moving at all.
Anxious to move on to the rest of his tasks,
Peter unleashes a small spider-shaped drone
from his backpack, which sneaks behind the
counter and opens up another passport pickup
line, which had been closed so that the postal
worker behind the glass could eat lunch.
It's not really necessary to understand the
rest of the film, but it's a clever little
bit of foreshadowing.
He needs a passport to travel abroad, and
his use of a drone is a small-scale version
how Quentin Beck will later use drones for
his master plan.
As part of his plan to woo MJ in Europe, Peter
wants to buy her a glass Black Dahlia necklace
in Venice, after which he'll give it to her
at the top of the Eiffel Tower.
The only problem is, he doesn't actually have
enough money to get the necklace, so he says
goodbye to a few prized possessions in pursuit
of some quick cash.
Peter heads to a pawn shop, carrying a box
of superhero action figures.
"Those are collectible action figures, and
they're worth more than your car!"
Although the camera only lingers on the box
for a second, making it difficult to tell
exactly which characters it contains, there
is one that Peter decides at the last second
not to pawn.
Plucking what appears to be a mostly yellow
figure from the box, Peter tells the pawn
shop owner that he's decided to keep "the
robot" after all.
This could be a nod to Peter's deep attachment
to Tony Stark, a man who essentially dressed
as a robot.
Or it could be someone we've never seen before.
If Sony and Marvel have really parted ways
for future Spidey films, it's questionable
whether any of the seed planting in Far from
Home will ever come to fruition.
This one likewise isn't necessary to the plot,
but it is a nice tip of the symbolic hat to
the fact that Far from Home marks the end
of Phase 3 of the MCU and a changing of the
superhero guard.
Next, Peter stops at at his local bodega,
where he purchases the dual headphone adapter
that is so crucial to his romantic goals.
After Peter makes a valiant but terrible attempt
to communicate what he's looking for in Spanish,
the bodega owner corrects him and sells him
the adapter, telling Peter he needs to work
on his "Spanglish."
Of course, Peter's plan for the dual headphone
adapter to use it to watch movies on the plane
with MJ goes tragically sideways, and he winds
up sitting next to his teacher Mr. Harrington
instead, while MJ and Peter's rival Brad watch
movies using the dual adapter that Brad also
happened to have with him.
The bodega scene was probably cut for a reason,
but it does drive home just how much effort
he put into getting all the pieces of his
plan to win over MJ right.
Finally, just before leaving the country,
Peter takes down a local organized crime syndicate
operating out of an Italian restaurant.
Wearing the Iron Spider suit that Tony gave
him in Avengers: Infinity War, Peter handily
dispatches a roomful of baddies while delivering
a barrage of quips about one-star Yelp reviews
and stingy tips.
The police compliment Peter on his new suit,
realizing it's obviously Stark tech.
"You gonna be the next Iron Man now?"
"Well, no, I don't have time.
I'm too busy doing your job."
"Ohhhh!"
"I'm kidding, I'm kidding!"
It's one of many reminders we get in Far from
Home that Peter is still grieving the loss
of Tony, a mental state that Beck takes full
advantage of.
It's a fun Spidey action sequence, but given
that there's no shortage of action and Tony
Stark reminders in Far from Home, it's easy
to understand why it didn't make the final
cut.
After Mysterio assumes he has killed Spider-Man,
he turns his sights to the other loose threads
in his plan Ned, MJ, and Betty.
He decides to stage a massive attack in London,
in which Mysterio will save the city from
an "Avengers-level threat," but not before
there are extensive civilian casualties, Peter's
friends included.
Beck gathers a group of his accomplices together
in a parking garage and reminds them to make
sure to take plenty of video and upload it
to the internet, since all the civilians who
would normally be posting to social media
will be dead.
After all, if Mysterio is going to be the
next Iron Man, he's going to have to go viral.
He then takes a call from Nick Fury, who informs
him of an Elemental threat in London, which,
of course, Beck planned.
The scene ends with Beck ending the call and
repeating his earlier line: "Never apologize
for being the smartest person in the room."
While this scene definitely drives home just
how far Beck is willing to go for the sake
of his plan, it pushes him a little too far
into cartoonish, mustache-twirling territory,
with his casual talk of dead innocents and
a catchphrase at the end.
While the scenes added to the Spider-Man:
Far from Home re-release mostly consist of
fun Spidey stuff, none of it really enhances
the plot or the characters in any meaningful
way.
It's all pretty superfluous, and in the case
of the Mysterio scene, may actually work to
the film's detriment.
The Peter-centric scenes are entertaining,
and the restaurant fight is a great opportunity
to see the Iron Spider suit in action one
last time.
Whether it's worth a return to the theater
depends on how much you liked Far from Home
to begin with, since it's basically the same
movie.
If you kind of wanted to see it again anyway,
or if you haven't managed to see it for the
first time, it's a good excuse to finally
go.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.